ohne russen gas gehen dann bei uns in
deutschland möglicherweise schon in
diesem herbst in diesem winter die
lichter aus erstaunlicher sparappell
kommt da von der regierung vom
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck der
von sich aus gehen sagt tust doch
weniger in deutschland ich robert habeck
so sagt er macht das doch schon lange
ich habe noch nie in meinem leben länger
als 5 minuten luft und jetzt verkürzt
sich das nochmals sagt er jetzt gerade
das hier sein aktuelles zitat schneller
check hier in der runde beim politiker
der mit in der regierung zeigten sie
schon an robert habeck chapel ich dich
bei der hitze immer kalt
unter und im winter wird das ist ja im
winter wird spannend im winter
durchschnitt kürzer kürzer ok dabei als
robert habeck chapel wie oft und wie
lange duschen sie klima aktiv ist bei
uns in der runde henning jeschke ich war
recht festgeklebt ist das frag mich ob
er die sendung umbenennen müssen wir die
richtige frage hieß sie jetzt in diesem
moment eigentlich nicht wie ich meine
stoppuhren jetzt testet beim duschen per
gericht aber ich kann das verstehen dass
wir jetzt sagen wir gucken wir mal für
das alle machen aber das ist eigentlich
eine lüge begonnen von der ölindustrie
die hat gesagt guck mir mal alle uns
unsere eigenen fußabdrücke an wieviel
machst du denn so was isst du denn
eigentlich so die bewegst du dich und
alle streiten sich und die die leute die
den privat jets über unsere köpfe
wegfliegen die lachen sich doch schlapp
dass wir können ja jetzt auch nicht bei
jeder frage sagen das ist totaler
quatsch ich habe hier die besseren
fragen nein aber ich nachgefragt weil
dann können wir beim nächsten mal
tauschen und sie moderieren deshalb
lassen sie uns einmal bei der frage
hierbei der grad in der
gesellschaftlichen kann das kind auch
wir sind exakt aber ist es auch gern
sich weniger an viel du stich sondern
wieviel werden insgesamt die hebel
umgestellt und dann darf man wegfahren
immer nur das hatten sehr selber
angesprochen gehen wir auf dein kleines
was machst du ein sondern hat sich die
firma sein und die großen hebel heißen
jetzt sofort den bahnverkehr anders
umbauen die verkehrswende mann stand
aber anstatt sache aber sie beschäftigen
sich nicht mit ihrem eigenen verhalten
also ist es wurscht wie sie zuhause
heizen oder wie lange die dusche läuft
das ist ja der punkt den robert habeck
anspricht der pakt ja uns am gewissen
das heißt sie fühlen sich da gar nicht
gepackt von robert habeck sagt er muss
halt an die langen hebel ran bei mir
zuhause wurst oder wie handhaben sie ich
habe eine große menge von leuten in der
gesellschaft ist auch schon seit
geraumer zeit
daran zu überlegen wie kann ich in
diesem klima notfall etwas verändern ja
eine tonne kostet natürlich auch jetzt
genau in der lebens zu groß wie viel da
die kosten kommen und im krieg was mache
ich das persönlich sind viele überlegen
aber das ganze wird ja nur dann groß
funktionieren das war schon immer
gesellschaftlich so dazu ist politik da
wenn ihr regeln insgesamt sagen so ist
der plan so kommen wir da raus und wenn
wir uns erwachsene sie wird zum angucken
heißt das wir müssen über die nächsten
fünf jahre sonst nämlich werden die
leute die jetzt neu geboren sind in
kriege geschickt die um die letzten
ressourcen bekämpft werden also
herrschte alles in ordnung hatte einfach
nicht die einfach einfach hier bereiten
könnte daher sein könnten tag das kann
ich ihnen alles sagen aber ich glaube
dies das ist nicht die entscheidende
fragen deswegen habe ich nicht gesagt es
ist die frage die die regierung
aufgeworfen hat uns gefehlt habe
schnittlich der weiß wie die leute
duschen soll wohl irgendwie am tag bei
elf minuten liegen ich glaube ja viele
kommen bei drei bis vier minuten aus
halten die temperatur oder gar nicht so
niedrig wie nur möglich ich darf noch
mal betont das einsparungspotenzial der
haushalte vergessen dass darunter ist
auch duschen aber es ist heizen es ist
auch kochen kennen und nun liegt bei
maximal 10 bis 15 die entscheidende
frage ist wegen felix wir sind uns der
springer investieren als user kampagne
an die bürgerinnen und bürger zu bringen
dass man sieht ich kann einen beitrag
leisten alle müssen einen beitrag in
dieser versorgungsmangel lage aber eine
aufklärungsarbeit muss für die bürger
auf schon darauf schon fast zynisch wenn
ein bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt du
schon ein bisschen weniger also ich
dusche nicht richtig durch und nicht
weniger weil ich sage dieser hebel ist
so klein ich weiß ja worüber wir reden
das ist wenn wir zehn prozent und
außerdem muss mal wissen die menschen
sind klug genug bei solchen dreifach
sechsfach steigenden gaspreisen schon
selber auf die idee zu kommen mit
energie vernünftig umzugehen das macht
übrigens jedes unternehmen also diese
appelle jetzt musste auch das
unternehmen ersparen die blöd sind die
denn eigentlich denken die eigentlich
den unternehmen das sind alles
schnarchnasen haben die ganze zeit
optimiert ich sage wir müssen können das
problem nur lösen wenn wir auf der
angebotsseite endlich mal die barrieren
brechen die in deutschland auf gestürmt
worden sind dann hat ein gas teurer und
verbot wir haben ein fracking verbot wir
haben ein kohle
zahlungsverkehr die forschung hier total
gut aus hamburg sie war im umwelt in
hamburg sie haben die beste zugänge sie
kennen kanzleramtschef den wolfgang
schmidt haushaltes la vida ist alles
weiß und man isst man muss aber immer
sehen dass die gesellschaftliche
diskussion wie sie im augenblick geführt
wird eben soweit noch nicht ist das
heißt der kanzler weise sei
alles nur abstellen und wir müssen jetzt
möglichst nur erneuerbarer machen das
wird aber nicht funktionieren und wir
müssen immer von der realität ausgehen
und ich sage ihnen voraus wenn
diejenigen die in diesem land
sozusagen das rückgrat bilden dieser
dieser volkswirtschaft und für unseren
wohlstand jeden tag morgens um 7 uhr zur
arbeit gehen das sind die ihnen essen
sorgen diese all das können sie mich mal
bitte ausreden lassen diese
undisziplinierter ist doch unglaublich
sie haben kann jetzt mal über die
katastrophe eigentlich geredet ja weil
es keine katastrophe gibt man lieber
machen sie doch mal schlau 0,3 grad das
ist doch gar nichts sie kleben sich
umsonst irgendwohin und stören ist nicht
gleich also den menschen hat er war ganz
was anderes nicht um ihre
fantastereien und ihre angst preziose
wie sie haben die gibt es nämlich gar
nicht 0,3 grad ist gar nichts im in den
nächsten 30 jahren das werden sie noch
hoffentlich auch als ergebnis hat das
wasser hat das so lange an korrigieren
weil in so einer runde sowas
unkommentiert stehen zu lassen ist
natürlich es ist gar nicht lang
kommentiert da ist habe sie sagen
erfahren holt er hat keine fakten
erfahren sagt die hin sie haben keine
nennen sie beim platzen moderator wie
sieht's aus herr jasch beantworten sie
einfach darauf sie sind in der lage sich
selber zu werden hier in dieser sendung
an fanden sie einfach auf erfahren heute
erfahren heute sagt es gibt keine
katastrophe er leugnet durch den
klimawandel das hat er nicht getan er
sagt aber der anstieg ist nicht so groß
und vor allen dingen sagt er wir sind
nicht die letzte generation wie sie das
sagen hat ihr aktivismus wie erfahren
holt offenbar sagt was religiöses
absolut also ich brauche das fegefeuer
und ich sehe wie egal es ist für unseren
weiteren verlauf was der liebe erfahren
heute sagt weil es einfach komplett
daran vorbei geht was die menschen
mittlerweile schon selber erleben ich
komme aus vorpommern da ist die
blaualgen blüte der deutsche wald jeder
spürt dem los und ich war 20 jahre es
ist klar dass das ganze jetzt gerade in
die kib situation kommt group sieht die
dürre in der landwirtschaft jedes jahr
mehr milliarden braucht und das wird
irgendwann nicht mehr über geld zu lösen
sein weil wenn das ökosystem einmal 90
seiten damit nur genau über die mittel
und die schließlich klar geworden was
verstanden dass wir immer noch darüber
streiten und ich dachte da sind die
leute einen schon weiter ich freue mich
wenn wir nicht mehr darüber streiten
müssen dass das eine notfall ist in dem
wir ganz ehrlich gesagt mal in den
nächsten zwei drei jahren noch
entscheiden können wie ob die also in
100 jahren wird man sich auf den
parkplätzen von supermärkten wenn es
noch welche gibt um reis schüsseln
kloppen und sich gegenseitig umbringen
das ist die zukunft in die wir kommen
und schon in den nächsten jahrzehnten es
ist ja gar nicht pessimistische es ist
ja ganz pessimistischen blick auf die
welt teilweise wird er eben nicht
geteilt es gibt einen optimistischen
blick auf die auf die welt dann sind sie
zwischen anbelangt keinen anlagen aber
keinen anderen auf die fakten aber wir
streiten doch hier über die mittel wie
gehen wir das andere was sind lösung das
interessiert auch unsere zuschauer zu
hause was hat beispielsweise die
hungerstreik gebracht im wahlkampf
können sie da sagen der protest auch das
leben auf der straße das hat bisher
etwas gebracht
es ist immer so wenn es die situation
gibt das gesellschaftlich sehen wir noch
mal bilder von ihnen verzeihen sie ja
das ist dieser hungerstreik im wahlkampf
der sie körperlich an die grenze geführt
hat
sofern wir das zumindest sehen konnten
was hat da es bewegt was hat das
gebracht genau wir sehen hier wie in den
momenten in denen in unserer
gesellschaft vor der vor der wahl
beispielsweise nicht darüber geredet
wird was eigentlich die leute besorgen
sollte kein anderer weg mehr dazu führt
dass das in die debatte ein fluss findet
auch hier nicht richtig in die debatte
ein fluss finden kann als darüber dass
man deswegen sitze ich ja hier sagt es
muss ganz anders gehen und das nicht nur
bei sich im kleinen stückchen sagt
sondern so war das in der geschichte
immer wieder wenn es katastrophale not
gibt das auf den straßen sagt das ist
der ort wo wenn eine regierung darin
versagt die menschen zu schützen die die
jetzt neu geboren werden davor zu
schützen dass sie an der außengrenze
wieder erleben die das richtig richtig
übel an formen annimmt wenn das nicht
geschafft ist das ist für sich und seine
schergen soll das nach im magistrat
einen massenerfolg ja genau und in der
rest soll brachte der ford ist doch dass
in der debatte mittlerweile klarer wird
wir können so nicht weitermachen noch
deutlicher wird jetzt darüber dass die
fossilen energien keine mehrheit mehr
haben jetzt versuchen einige verzweifelt
im ringen um ihre letzten profite das
wieder zur etablieren
so wird das erste was hersteller sagen
dass er für die letzte generation
spricht was ist das ist das in ihren
augen ein stück anmaßend wenn er das
formulieren dass viel zu viel
pessimismus für die zukunft wir haben
doch in jeder phase der
menschheitsgeschichte selbst auch
kontrolle darüber erlangt wie wir wieder
in die zukunft kommen es gab immer große
krisen es gab immer große
herausforderungen für die menschheit und
es gab immer aber auch die möglichkeit
ist selbst zu prägen und deswegen ja es
ist anmaßend über er instrumente die
dafür sorgen dass der rest der
gesellschaften gestört wird und zwar bei
vielleicht auch der gerade dabei diesen
wandel hervor zu vorzunehmen dabei dabei
irgendwie zu stören und ich meine die
debatte können wir auch führen wenn sie
mich auf der straße fest gehen wir
können sie sogar besser führen sind sie
nicht auf der straße festkleben
heute
doch weil jetzt lassen sie mich aus und
ich habe sie auch ausreden lassen sie
nehmen immer einzelergebnisse um dann zu
sagen das nehmen wir jetzt ganz groß und
dann haben wir ein riesenproblem so ist
die welt aber nicht sie lesen als erstes
mal den 1,5 grad bericht des pcs die
sagen atomenergie die sagen also ccs
technologie und dieser wir müssen das
alles machen und dann suchen sie sich
wenn sie denn dafür hier sprechen nicht
mehr einzelne sachen davon aus die sie
besonders gut und besonders die sorge
dass das alles hier sorgen drei mal
dazwischen da sehr richtiges verein ein
blackout experten dazwischen wir
streiten darüber auch welchen hebel wir
eigentlich haben und da sagte jeschke
wir haben nur den ganz großen hebel wir
können hier über die kleinigkeiten über
die peanuts und so weiter sprechen
bringt aber nichts wir müssen die ganz
große party ich war jetzt schon wissen
ganz kurz die fragen hervor ich würde
schon wissen weil das ja hochspannung
mit blick auf herbst und winter es gibt
es eigentlich so was wie den kleinen
energie hebel von uns allen der aber was
ganz großes bewirkt wenn wir das alle
tun denn das ist ja was was robert
habeck insinuiert wo sie sagen ist
quatsch alle weniger duschen und es
bewegt richtig was gibt so war jeder
einzelne von uns
bürgerinnen bürger zu hause oder in
einem unternehmen auch im handwerks
mittelständischen unternehmen im
dienstleistungssektor kann ein gewisses
einsparungspotenzial erreichen dieses
einsparungspotenzial reicht aber nicht
aus
60% minderleistung von russland oder 100
prozent zu kompensieren insbesondere
wenn wir dann andere energieträger
auslaufen lassen ich darf er dann wir
haben drei akw s jedes bringt 1400
megawatt also 1,4 gigawatt wenn wir 4,2
gigawatt die 8000 nennen lässt stunden
im jahr haben vom netz nehmen haben eine
grundlast die nicht mehr da ist darf
erinnern
2020 hatten wir erneuerbaren energie
anteil an der stromversorgung 47 prozent
dann kam 2021 eine leichte delle 42
prozent wir haben 20 jahre gebraucht um
mit erneuerbaren energien wenn ich den
begriff überhaupt so gebrauchen kann den
energie kann weder erzeugt vernichtet
noch erneuert werden das ist ja schon
der punkt in der sache wir haben 20
jahre gebraucht für 47 prozent
ich glaube wenn wir zurzeit 1000
windräder haben die wir nicht mit trotz
genehmigung an den markt bringen weil
die baugenehmigungen nicht da sind die
umsetzung die stadt mit unternehmen die
das schaffen dann werden wir in den
nächsten zehn jahren nicht die
verdoppelung hinkriegen wir werden
vielleicht auf 50 55 prozent kommt wir
werden aber dennoch eine dunkelblaue
haben in der nacht die es im winter
wesentlich länger im sommer kürzer wir
werden flauten in der wind phase haben
die photovoltaik wird dunkel bleiben
bestimmten sachen und dann darf ich
betonen wir erleben heute das wie ein g
7 gipfel haben deutschland als viert
wichtiges industrieland kann ich ein
agrarland werden es brauch am tag zur
spitzenzeit 70 75 gigawatt also 75
tausend megawatt in der nacht 40 45.000
wenn ich dir aber nicht erzeugen kann
durch erneuerbaren energien wird sich
jeder unternehmer fragen wo bekomme ich
meine energie wir haben als
bundesverband festgestellt dass wir
schon im kleinen bereich im
millisekundenbereich im sekundenbereich
große ausfälle haben die zum beispiel
eine bäckerei unternehmen sofort im
bereich 500.000 euro schaden bei nur
wenigen sekunden hinter einfahren wir
brauchen eine energie die immer da ist
die keine schwankungen hat und die
einander nahe kunden wenn das passiert
die firmen gehen einfach dahin wo
energie usa die strom und gas ist nur
ein viertel so teuer wie was ist ihr
großer hebel sozusagen wenn wir hier
über die kleinigkeiten über die peanuts
gesprochen haben über das was wir zu
hause tun können tun sollten
möglicherweise was ist der große hebel
der uns ein gewinn bringt schon herbst
winter meine große hoffnung ist dass wir
mit den tabus die wir aufgebaut haben in
einer selbstzufriedenheit der letzten
zehn jahre geht doch schon irgendwie
dass wir damit jetzt mal in dieser
krisensituation
brechen als sonst aber eins ist eigene
gasförderung in einem jahr haben wir so
viel gas mache auch nur dass russen gas
da bin ich der fdp sei dank war
ich finde die fdp sehr dankbar ich hoffe
dass die sozialdemokraten endlich auch
verstehen dass das vernünftig ist und
die gewerkschaften auch
entsprechend einheizen hat eine große
werkschau und das zweite ist wir machen
wir müssen die enttabuisierung der der
der kohle thematisieren das heißt wir
müssen uns damit beschäftigen wie machen
wir coole sau beachten die grünen haben
wir
waren die machen kohle für sechs monate
und dann ist alles wieder gut dann
wollen wir weg davon aber wir müssen
noch bitterer für zwei jahre für 7,5
jahren aber auch für zwei jahre wird ist
ja nicht reichen wir werden ja auch in
zwei jahren noch energie brauchen und
wir haben die große chance wir haben die
technologie im land gehabt wie es war in
brandenburg die technologie zur co2
abscheidung entwickelt die sind dann
nach kanada ausgewandert und das werk
ist abgerissen worden in kanada wieder
aufgebaut worden wir haben die techniker
wir haben ingenieure das zu entwickeln
damit china das ist nämlich der
entsprechende mit 30 prozent des co2
weltweit endlich seine kohle schätze
nicht einfach so in die luft pusten darf
sondern abscheiden muss weil wir sagen
wir können das auch das ist ein bisschen
teurer das kostet sicherlich drei und
damit
wir werden irgendwann russland auch mit
russland wieder reden können nach diesem
krieg und nach kopien und es wäre völlig
blödsinnig zu sagen wir werden diese
pipeline nie mehr nutzen das wäre doch
absurd da ist die diplomatie gefragt zu
sagen wir werden auch verkohlten danach
wollte ich es zu ende ist glaubt ihre
regierung nicht dass sie das durchhält
glaubt nicht dass dass wir das hier
soziale spannungen geben sie die preise
durch die decke wir wenn wir gas
rechnungen von 2000 euro betroffenen
menschen in der ukraine abzuschlachten
und da wird überhaupt nicht darüber dass
überhaupt nicht aber rede ich jetzt ne
ich habe nur gesagt wir werden russland
in fünf jahren nicht von der größe
vertilgen das wird sie werden das wir
wollten sollten auch nicht so
weit treiben dass das gesamte erdgas
sozusagen in china landet das ist eine
koalition die ich auch nicht so gerne
habe also insofern diese offen
eine bilanz von jamaika sei ein paar
jahre klar und das dritte tabu ist eben
wir brauchen wieder gerne
energieforschung weil wir haben nämlich
noch ein problem das dürfe nicht
vergessen ja durch die kernenergie haben
wir alt lassen wir haben radioaktive
abfälle die in deutschland keine lösung
haben die werden an den kernkraftwerken
in
zwischenlagern gehortet dass
technik